[Music]
this is a typical eighteenth-century
manor house it's also the home of Barry
null the building contractor lived for
many years in Switzerland before he
returned to his native land good morning
welcome to my house do come in
a century ago this was the residence of
the bailiff of Jersey the islands top
administrator today it offers space
enough for Barry Knowles two daughters
and their families
[Music]
we love the grounds because a beautiful
outside garden I think that loved this
entrance hall and just to share space of
the various rooms it was better than
anything else be could find when we
moved back so we we looked at dozen
houses and this was our favorite by far
the family only uses the dining room for
special occasions daughter Jasmine
decided on the interior design it was
her idea to paint the wood paneling a
light color it gives everything a fresh
look before all the wood was original
and orange and then the walls were just
the white wallpaper but I stripped them
all back and doing that I found some of
the original wallpaper so then I chose
to go with a similar wallpaper that I
liked a new one but quite floral and
natural the wallpaper comes from a
collection that's based on design
patterns from the British Museum
[Music]
the fireplace is original the family
take their meals in the adjacent kitchen
[Music]
the chandeliers in the living room may
be a bit uber posh otherwise subdued
shades dominate
[Music]
when we first moved in it was very regal
and grand and there was a lot of gold
and red which we don't really like and
we didn't feel very at home here so we
just tried to neutralize it and make it
a lot lighter and fresher cleaner and
just more homely this is my favorite
wallpaper it's from Andrew Martin and
it's of love letters from the second
world war but I had a big argument with
my dad choosing it because he wanted he
didn't really want it in here and I
wanted the whole room to be like this so
we compromised and I have one little
wall with it but I think it would have
looked better if it had been everywhere
the living room looks out onto the
conservatory which is where the family
prefer to spend their time when Barry
wants some quiet he withdraws to the
smoking-room jasmine did the interior
design in there too just as everywhere
else in the house the walls are trimmed
with the work of his favorite artist
Edmund Blum p-well Edmund bump is the
most famous of Jersey artists so it fits
into an old jersey house very nicely we
like his work both etchings oil
paintings watercolors sand it's quite
fun tried to collect them at various
auctions around the world there are 800
square meters in the 10 room house all
the bedrooms are on the first and second
floors the maze-like hallways create a
feeling of intimacy and privacy
[Music]
now this is the only one we really kept
the same because I just love the high
ceilings and the neutral colors and I
love the bed that was here when we
bought the house and it just makes me
feel like a princess in here a separate
bath and dressing room emphasized the
luxurious style of the house
[Music]
at 10,000 square meters the garden is
huge it provides plenty of protection
from prying eyes when we came back to to
Jersey we just came in through the gates
of the driveway we just we just loved
what we saw and they got just got better
from there onwards we went inside we
loved the inside so we decided that was
the house for us in fact it's now a home
for three generations and it's managed
to hold on to its old-time charm even
after its modern facelift
[Music]